You know when a craving hits and you can't stop thinking about it?
Ever since I started using the new Lineage
Watermelon Pop Lip Sleeping Mask,
I've been thinking about having watermelon lavender sorbet.
So today I just decided to finally make it.
So I started by making a simple syrup by combining some water,
sugar, and lavender.
After letting that boil and steep,
I transferred it over to a glass jar to cool off.
In the meantime, I cut up my watermelon.
Nothing screams summer more than having a good watermelon.
So I cut it in half
and then took the skin off before slicing it into little spears,
transferred them over to my blender, and I did this in batches,
blended it up, and then strained it through a strainer.
At this point
I added in my lavender simple syrup before giving that a good mix,
adding some lemon juice and lemon zest,
and I transferred it over to my ice cream Turner
and let that go until it got a little bit more solid.
I couldn't resist trying some,
so I had two scoops and it was absolutely divine.